[Applause]
live tv
here we go regina king nearly takes a
tumble
and also delivers a powerful message
about social justice
while opening the 2021 oscars
if things had gone differently this past
week in minneapolis
i might have traded in my heels for
marching boots
oscar winner regina king kicked off
hollywood's biggest night in
a creative way the show which was
hostless this year
instead opted for a cinematic movie
style opening
on-screen credits and all
[Music]
yeah that single shot followed regina
all the way through the show's venue
union station la and naturally she was
clutching her oscar gold
the actress looked breathtaking in a
custom gown by louis vuitton
which included structured wing sleeves
and 62
000 sequins the embroidery alone took
140
hours ladies
once regina took the stage she tried to
get situated but
stumbled a bit literally but of course
she recovered
like a true pro
[Applause]
live tv here we go then she took the
opportunity to make a few important
points
starting with social justice and
hollywood's response
i have to be honest if things have gone
differently this past week in
minneapolis
i might have traded in my heels for
marching boots
now i know that
a lot of you people at home want to
reach for your remote
when you feel like hollywood is
preaching to you but
as a mother of a black son i know the
fear that so many live with
and no amount of fame a fortune changes
that
okay but the one night in miami director
also made it clear
that the oscars are a celebration
this was indeed a hard year for everyone
but
our love of movies helped to get us
through
it made us feel less isolated and
connected us when we were apart
now like all of you here i've loved
movies for as long as i can remember
and yes we are doing it maskless yes
you are probably asking how are they
able to do that well
think of this as a movie set
an oscars movie with a cast of over 200
nominees
people have been vast tested retested
socially distanced and we are following
all of the rigorous protocols
that got us back to work safely so
just like on a movie set when we're
rolling
masks off and when we're not rolling
masks on the celebrated performer opened
up to e.t
in january about making her film
directorial debut with one night in
miami
and regina shared the poignant message
she hopes the audience takes away
i don't ever remember having the
opportunity seeing
four men black men um
uh realized in in in a complex way
in a way that this is how i see the men
in my life
and so it was my intention that you know
when you
and and anyone that that that that i
loving
any black man that i love and respect
sees this film
they see themselves
you